[Music]
it's time for each ease social study
your quick look at what the stars are
posting online Zac Efron took his fans
along for a desert adventure on
Instagram complete with camels and
shirtless snaps Lea Michele also sexed
it up sharing these steamy bathing suit
pics on her account I'm very comfortable
in my skipper meanwhile Tina Lawson
threw it back to beyonce's at wedding
day nine years ago caption to this shot
that's my arm fixing the dress LOL also
ringing the lols this pic from Naomi
Watts catching a fan is snapping a shot
of her on the subway it's from almost a
year ago but the Internet has just
tracked it down the sneaky snap the fan
took a little bit of role reversal going
on then there's duck dynasty star Sadie
Robertson announcing she's at taking a
break from social media I just need to
get away and and just really focus on my
life Lena Dunham says she is officially
endometriosis free after going her fifth
procedure this year her boyfriend at
Jack Antonoff shared this post surgery
pick up the star and congrats are in
order for Martin Lawrence and his
longtime love Roberta they're engaged